saludo en directo América el día de hoy
se celebra el Día Mundial de la
solidaridad de intersexual esta fecha
sirve también para que hagamos una
reflexión en torno a las problemáticas y
vulneraciones que cifren que sufren
estas personas y para ello pues para
hablar de este tema me acompaña Marina
sardiña con toda la información de salud
Marina Buenos días Ángela también
recordemos que el 26 de octubre se
celebra el día por la visibilidad de la
intersexualidad y vamos a hacer un
repaso sobre esta este concepto no
tradicionalmente nos hemos movido en un
binarismo normativo hombre mujer a
través del sexo biológico o asignado que
es la etiqueta que nos asigna el doctor
al nacer según una serie de factores
fisiológicos como los genitales hormonas
y los cromosomas que tenemos que tenemos
los las personas no los espermatozoides
tienen un cromosoma X y el óvulo tiene
un cromosoi y el lóbulo tiene un
cromosoma X una persona con cromosoma X
y suele tener órganos y reproductivos
asociados como masculinos y en cambio
con cromosomas XX suelen asociarse con
los femeninos esto no excluye que se den
otras combinaciones de cromosomas
hormonas y órganos que serían las
personas intersexuales y que es la
intersexualidad Ángela lo primero es
mentir algunos mitos porque durante años
se llamó hermafroditas a las personas
intersex Pero el hermafroditismo es una
condición Que solo se produce en
animales y plantas sin embargo la
intersexualidad son personas que nacen
con características sexuadas es decir
genitales no normativos alteración de
gónadas alteración de los niveles
hormonales o cromosómicos cromosómicos
pueden ser variaciones a nivel anatómico
o genético de las características
sexuales que se ajustan a las categorías
típicas de masculino o femenino
recordemos que el 1,7 de la población
mundial nace con corporalidad e
intersexual no es una orientación sexual
hay que recordar Ángela no es una la
capacidad de género no es una patología
y no es un tercer sexo Ángela
precisamente Marina Y con toda esta
cátedra que nos está dando existen más
de 80 tipos de intersexualidades así es
cada persona es un mundo y existen
muchos tipos y condiciones y para
ampliar este tema tenemos con nosotras
desde México a freez ella es integrante
de la pionera organización mexicana
brújula intersexual que lucha por la
visibilización de las personas
intersexuales y sus derechos Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotras en
francés 24 free lo primero que quería
preguntarte es qué es cuando se reconoce
una persona está condición de
intersexualidad Y también si nos puedes
contar un poquito de tu caso
Buenos días y muchas gracias por la
invitación bien como ya dijiste la
intersexualidad es una palabra que se
refiere a una amplia variedad de
situaciones del cuerpo en las que unas
personas nace con características
sexuales como genitales gónadas niveles
cromosómicos o patrones hormonales que
no parecen encajar en las definiciones
típicas de masculino o femenino por
ejemplo una mujer con barba o con un
clítoris considerado más grande de lo
normal un hombre con un pene más pequeño
de lo considerado normal o bien una
persona pueden hacer con cromosomas x y
con una corporalidad femenina la
intersexualidad no siempre se hace
evidente al nacer algunas personas
descubren que tienen una variación
intersexual hasta la pubertad cuando no
se presentan los cambios corporales
esperados para una mujer o para un
hombre típi
free también cuéntanos un poco Cuáles
son estas Barreras discriminaciones y
vulneraciones médicas que sufren estas
personas a lo largo de su vida y cómo
son las afectaciones también a nivel
físico y a nivel emocional
bien Sí el protocolo médico incluye
cirugías genitales y tratamientos
médicamente
innecesarios tratamientos invasivos
tratamientos dolorosos que se realizan a
edades muy tempranas en las que el
consentimiento informado no es posible a
estos procedimientos se les conoce como
prácticas de mutilación genital
intersexual y conllevan secuelas físicas
y mentales como
la sensibilidad genital total o parcial
cicatrices
dolor
infecciones recurrentes así como
depresión ansiedad trastornos de estrés
postraumático etcétera También pasamos
por situaciones en las que se nos
niega a conocer nuestro derecho a la
verdad porque
médicos y hospitales comúnmente se
niegan a entregar nuestro expediente
médico también hace falta muchos
psicólogos y médicos capacitados y
sensibilizados que ofrezcan una atención
di informada y eficiente a las personas
intersexuales por ejemplo me gustaría
mencionar que yo tengo una amiga que
vive en una comunidad muy marginada en
el estado de Oaxaca en la que no hay
muchos servicios de salud solo tienen un
centro de salud y ella tiene dos hijas
con variaciones intersexuales y ahí en
su comunidad la variación de sus hijas
salió a la luz por parte de la enfermera
del centro de salud que empezó a
divulgar información diciendo que sus
hijas
eran hermafroditas y empezó a divulgar
información acerca de las
características sexuales de las hijas de
mi amiga y eso se volvió un problema
para ella tanto que tuvo que cambiarse
del lugar de residencia y otro problema
que también enfrentamos es que hace
falta información en los medios de
comunicación que no se consulta
comúnmente a las personas intersex al
hablar del tema esos procedimientos
médicos de los que ya hablamos son
irreversibles y nos afectan a lo largo
de nuestras vidas
sí le habla Ángela Gómez y gracias por
estar con nosotros que hace falta a
nivel Social para la visibilización de
la intersexualidad para su aceptación su
reconocimiento Y pues también desde la
comunidad médica que usted nos
mencionaba
yo creo que hace falta más información
acerca de lo que es la intersexualidad
más talleres para la visibilización de
la intersexualidad de los problemas que
enfrentamos hace falta tomar en cuenta a
las organizaciones intersecta Al momento
de hablar de la intersexualidad en los
medios de comunicación yo les agradezco
a ustedes por tomarnos en cuenta para
hablar de ese tema en brújula
intersexual lo valoramos y también
quiero decir que es importante hacerle
saber a la población que las personas
intersexuales somos reales existimos y
resistimos a pesar de la estigmatización
y la violencia que sufrimos en este día
de la solidaridad intersexual quiero
invitar a la audiencia que nos ve a que
se una a nuestra causa y compartan la
información proporcionada por
organizaciones intersex
por último así muy brevemente frita me
quería preguntarte desde parte del
movimiento feminista y lgbtiqmat
últimamente se están cuestionando
conceptos o categorías como género o
sexo porque es necesario revisar estos
términos muy brevemente
bueno esa pregunta es un tanto compleja
es muy importante revisarlos porque
vivimos en una sociedad que
está regida por un sistema
heteronormativo
está regida por la ignorancia y por los
prejuicios que tiende a rechazar lo que
es diferente si bien la intersexualidad
implica una variación en las
características
sexuales
se habla mucho de lo que es el sexo y el
género
al nacer o desde que somos pequeños en
el sistema médico buscan la manera de
asignarnos un sexo tratando de corregir
nuestros cuerpos que no hay nada que
corregir pero como tienen la patologizar
nuestra situación tienen asignarnos un
sexo que si está bien que se nos asigne
un sexo pero también hay que pensar en
en el futuro así como a cualquier otra
persona
podemos no identificarnos con ese sexo o
con ese género
y es común que manden a las personas
intersexuales a
sesiones psicológicas para saber su sexo
psicológico Y así también según
orientarlos o guiarlos hacia la
identificación con el sexo también que
se les fue asignado
mucho tiempo Yo le agradezco mucho por
esta explicación y pues invitamos a
nuestros televidentes a que puedan
consultar más en el brújula intersexual
Gracias también a ustedes Marina y bueno
Vamos a continuar ahora con nuestro
invitado del día